[Music]
lolo new or do is clearing a path to the
hippos protected area when it's hot the
hippos retreat to the bushes to graze a
lot of circles harmony hippos are there
here around 30 according to noir do but
they're hiding in the thickets and the
chances of seeing them are slim we can't
go any further it's too dangerous the
hippos become aggressive when they're
disturbed look learnedly +1 they always
come this way this morning they passed
through here and then moved on towards
the border of the protected zone where
they know they'll be left in peace Lou
Gramm barachiel Abajo surah [ __ ] lava
the village of a fetal is home to about
300 people there without electricity
there's no school here are no medical
facilities there are sixty communities
like a fit outlining the five lakes in
the Nature Reserve fish stocks are
thriving in Lake a fee because of the
hippos predators leave the fish alone
and they can flourish fishermen use
large mesh Nets to reduce bycatch they
head out in groups of two and three
yo did it maybe I got no man we go out
in the morning and we return with 20 to
40 fish a day Bloody ell onion in it
their catch is so plentiful that the
needs of every family are covered the
women say sometimes the fishermen catch
up to 200 fish a few years ago they were
only catching a third of that amount
these days they can even sell on some of
the catch as a result they no longer
hunt hippos once the fisherman returned
to shore the lakes fish stocks are
monitored to see how much they're
allowed to catch next time out the done
in the past there were conflicts between
humans and hippos at one point things
were so bad that the hippos had almost
disappeared but now we've raised
people's awareness we've established a
conservation project and the hippos are
left in peace gomez bah Damini defective
we've succeeded by involving the locals
and Environmental Protection and now
every species is left to thrive in its
natural habitat you may start soon it
took more than 10 years before the local
communities grew accustomed to allowing
the animals to follow their own nature
twice a day Lauryn Ward oh and his team
of conservationists come to the viewing
platforms from here they can look out
across the entire conservation area cye
over there along the banks of the lake
is the heart of the area it's a closed
conservation area people aren't allowed
to enter it that's where the hippos
breathe the fish to where there are
hippos there are fish we set up these
enclaves which they can retreat to know
and where they can be left in peace in
order to preserve the species Rupo there
desipapa here in togas lake region
nature conservation played a big part in
celebrations to mark this year's
International Women's Day local women
from the communities in and around the
Nature Reserve were invited to an event
where they could discuss ideas share
their experiences and enjoy themselves
[Music]
women play a key role when it comes to
making nature conservation a cornerstone
of community life altima tlie its women
who bear the brunt if nature is
destroyed so protecting it is in our own
interest so that's why we share our
experiences and discuss what we can do
to guide and assist our men danielson
yah yah yah it all ties together
biodiversity the lakes the hippos we do
everything we can to protect them
because that means they'll be fish we
can sell it's all part of a cycle netaji
and that's why we protect nature in an
ASA the nature conservationists take us
on a tour of the leg this time they are
hoping to know other hippos out of their
hiding places
we spend a few hours waiting but there's
no sign of any hippos suddenly there's a
rustling in the reeds the advil bully
investigates and comes back all excited
the only hippos were going to see today
are the ones on his mobile phone he
climbed a treat shaky images what a wad
up what does alone booyaka good you can
see how fast this area is it's huge
there are so many places they could hide
and we'd never find those in every
little the hippos of Lake affion just a
myth and the locals would like nothing
more than to boost their incomes by
kick-starting and ecotourism industry
realistically though it'll be the next
generation that benefits offered daily
what would uncle Costa to of course the
hippos are a major factor they would be
at the center of our ecotourism concept
they live here in the lake a lake that
belongs to our conservation area we just
don't know what our HIPAA policy should
be limited by uncle the locals are
currently planning to set up feeding and
bathing areas in the lakes for the
hippos that would make it easier to
locate them during day time hopefully by
the end of the decade visitors to the
region will be enjoying the sight of
bathing HIPAA